and welcome to this video playing Shang
Nakia Nakia yeah new opponent displayed
quite a number of games so he play some
offbeat an opening here though what is
called actually 96 let's keep it simple
really not playing well at the moment I
don't want something super complicated
probably DD takes d5 is not the way to
try to review this but 10 yeah like to
get on the score what if it was
something simple we should be for my
mind winning stuff he just he just takes
them and so what's going on here Miami
taking the loop here and I said working
98 he takes on b5 em with a check can
place III end to my night is someone to
trapped on check check the cool thing is
that he plays it everything everything
instantly like it's the easiest thing in
the world maybe it is it wouldn't be
it's not easy for me so this
so I am an exchange of careful porn
check for two pounds yeah doesn't make
it easy maybe I should hope everyone
here don't know maybe we'll see so look
f1 route create assess is good for me
you good idea maybe shake and rook the
to plot Jim this position is very
compact this is very difficult to do
something here with white trading is a
mistake though I ok yes Bishop b5 ok ok
then it's all a mistake technical to
teach if you don't want to trade rooks
but it was ok here of course if you can
take both pawns Rukia one Bishop t5 Luke
SN Bishop g2 roster what's the problem
okay and b5 yes leave only interesting
of him see playing this right so a seven
and then see to look a wonder hug a one
Roxy 1 i'm sorry so I keep be five I got
rid of this that's not good that's not
good at all now that that's not good to
them that I allowed this somehow shoot
timeline that's bad right now winning
chances go down to 0 basically if the if
my B point is traded
h5 are fond of it surprising
well what's going on here it won't be
enough
we won't be enough maybe ok this is a
pretty favorable situation yeah that
this is this is winning now I think ok
eight and I can take
let's do it in a second's check check
check check check mate hmm ok so I
managed to win this ending which wasn't
wasn't really possible yeah maybe he
tried to win and screw it up for this
reason I think trying to win for black
waters was not not very realistic the
way it will pan out but I could be wrong
of course so after this is really
strange and have a hard time to believe
in the same yeah so now geforce Virginia
hmm so for this engine suggestion here
takes let me get this into the picture
yeah this is what the computer suggests
Wow if the funny thing is that dumb yeah
something like this is this is just
winning that he actually has this move
and it traps the night yeah this is a
pretty coincidental thing at the night
if it's no square yeah I mean wow ok I
took here cat chalice c3 and i took with
this and he is ok because of the check
the roof coming iron is this and now
probably look everyone yeah who gave one
is probably stronger yeah and maybe I
shouldn't even try what I tried I
thought I didn't
long that it can actually take a 2 which
is the thing I thought that he can never
take because this this and I get a 7
back but in this line he gets this taken
can this chica take this and this I
didn't want to play because this looks
very good for him that's it easy to play
at three against one and if you like
this must be really good for black and
easier to play than the game and here i
think i think don't think black can win
this he doesn't get connected pawns on
the on the on the queenside until the
way it the way it went and he had to be
cautious yeah this is also helping me
but doing it it should be a drop of
course though my king cakes was stronger
yes it was stronger here because of
discovery no a 6k 71 squid borderline
maybe it seems to hotel I mean he only
has two probably trade this off and find
some setup with bishop only six that is
a draw I mean in the game in the game we
got something like this yeah here but he
played with g6 and I think this was
wrong this gives me a clear entry square
I think g6 is one of those typical
routine blitz moves that you don't need
to play and i think is actually not
helping him here if he keeps this puts a
bishop only six I don't don't see why
win again but with the g6 I mean you saw
it it actually was relatively easy yeah
here single king is
this is this is better maybe still a
draw I do this something that that could
still be a draw but once i went to have
six senses over where you cannot you
cannot prevent this cat in here I'm just
too quick and it's a win against the
Jeep horn so far no big problem here
provide even with little time on the
clock okay we like to have stopped the
bleeding and come back over 2,200 again
thanks for watching